choisissez un travail que vous aimez et
vous n'aurez pas à travailler un seul
jour de votre vie
confucius je m'appelle à magna broussy
j'ai 21 ans et mon métier ses assistants
en soins et santé communautaire
cela fait une année que j'exerce mon
métier et j'ai un parcours un petit peu
particulier
je vous explique j'ai effectué la
majorité de ma scolarité obligatoire
dans le canton de genève pendant
laquelle j'ai énormément entendu parler
du collège par la suite j'ai déménagé
avec mes parents et mes soeurs en valais
là où j'ai effectué mes deux dernières
années de scolarité obligatoire primaire
est mon cycle d'orientation
j'ai décidé par la suite de d'effectuer
ma dernière année du cycle d'orientation
dans le haut valais à sa seconde et
pendant toute cette période là j'ai
vraiment entendu parler du collège de
les cg ou de l'école de commerce
principalement ça faisait deux mois que
j'étais arrivé dans ma classe à sa
seconde quand la conseillère en
orientation est venu nous voir pour la
première fois inutile de vous expliquer
que j'ai pas compris grand chose de ce
qu'elle nous a raconté donc j'étais pas
beaucoup plus avancés sur mon avenir
professionnel
la marraine est infirmière j'ai toujours
beaucoup aimé quand elle nous racontait
des histoires d'hôpital
puis j'aimais bien grey's anatomy aussi
donc quand on a dû choisir un lieu de
stage pour pendant notre dernière année
je me suis dit pourquoi pas découvrir
l'hôpital
le problème c'est qu'à l'époque j'avais
14 ans et que partout dans tous les
centres hospitaliers ils ne prennent des
stagiaires qu'à partir de 16 ans le seul
hôpital qui a bien voulu de moi comme
stagiaire c'était l'hôpital de viège
une fois de plus tout en allemand le
premier jour que j'arrive en stage je
suis une infirmière
le premier sens qu'elle me montre c'est
d'enlever des agrafes sur un patient
dont on vous parle d' agrafes c'est au
sens littéraire et littéral du mot donc
vraiment des agrafes comme sur une
feuille sauf sur la hanche de mon
patient sur à peu près 30 cm moi qui
avais jamais mis les pieds dans une
chambre d'hôpital
je vous explique que la pauvre
infirmière eu le temps d'enlever trois
agrafes avant de me ramasser par terre
j'avais fait un malaise
ma carrière dans les soins commençait
plutôt mal mais j'ai quand même adoré
mon stage et particulièrement le service
de néonatologie qui accueille les bébés
prématurés c'est à dire les
ils sont nés trop tôt ou les bébés qui
naissent à terme mais avec des problèmes
par la suite j'avais donc décidé de
devenir infirmière
je me suis donc dirigé vers l'école de
culture générale
ça n'a pas fait très long avant que je
me rende compte que c'était très
théorique et que ça me n'est pas
vraiment concrètement en fait à mon
métier d'infirmière je m'ennuyais on
fait un peu à l'école
donc je suis allé voir ma conseillère en
orientation je lui ai expliqué caley tel
problème et elle m'a présenté
l'apprentissage d'assistante en soins
par la suite j'avais donc décidé de me
lancer là dedans
le problème c'est que à cette période là
j'avais passé déjà la date des
postulations donc j'étais obligé de
continuer une année de plus avant de
pouvoir partir en apprentissage c'est
inutile de vous dire qu'avec le peu de
motivation et d'investissement que j'ai
mis dans mon année scolaire je les ai
échoué gelé donc recommencer pour
pouvoir avoir quelque chose à faire en
attendant de partir en apprentissage et
quand enfin est arrivé le moment où
j'avais le droit de postuler
j'ai fait un dossier un seul pour
l'hôpital du valais quand je suis allé
le peaufiner avec ma conseil
d'orientation elle m'a regardé dans les
yeux et lui a dit mademoiselle grossi
j'espère que vous avez une deuxième
option
parce qu'à l'hôpital du valais y
prennent que les meilleurs et vu votre
échec l'année passée vous avez très peu
voire aucune chance de pouvoir intégrer
le réseau santé valais je lui ai répondu
tech tel quel ce sera l'hôpital du
valais ou rien c'était ça et pas autre
chose
le 1er août 2015 j'ai non seulement
commencé mon apprentissage d'assister à
l'hôpital du valais mais en plus je vais
commencer dans le service de pédiatrie
et ça s'explique par le fait que quand
ils ont vu mon dossier quand ils ont lu
ma lettre de motivation et mon prix en
entretien et pendant mon entretien
je leur ai expliqué ma motivation je
leur ai dit pourquoi elle avait choisi
ce métier là et ils ont décidé de me
donner une chance au début de ma
dernière année d'apprentissage
on m'a présenté lé championnat valaisan
des assistantes en soins j'y voyais pas
vraiment l'intérêt à ce moment là je
vois là je ne me voyais pas faire ça je
voyais pas pourquoi je ferais ça est une
amie de formation m'a tapé le coude et
mahdi vient on y va on essaye
j'en voyais pas vraiment l'intérêt mais
elle m'a dit ça peut être un bon
entraînement pour nos examens pratiques
qui arrive à la fin de l'année donc
c'est vrai qu'elle a des raisons donc je
me suis dit bon ciel fait avec moi on
sera deux ce sera sympa pourquoi pas
essayer donc on s'est lancé dans la
préparation des championnats valaisan
des assistantes en soins quand j'ai reçu
la situation quelques jours quelques
semaines avant les championnats
vous allez peut-être rire mais sa
traitait d'un patient qui venait de se
faire opérer de la hanche etc avec des
agrafes
non seulement on s'était le premier soin
que j'avais vu de toute ma carrière mais
en plus c'est un soin de chirurgie chez
un patient passablement âgées et moi
j'avais déjà fait deux ans de formation
chez les enfants donc le soin en théorie
je l'avais eue je le connaissais n'y
avait pas de problème mais n'avait pas
beaucoup soigner d'adultes je savais pas
comment j'allais me prendre je me suis
dit qu'on allait essayer de toute façon
on n'avait rien à perdre comme ces
données la feuille ammar a manqué
infirmière elle à lui de la situation
elle a rigolé al mahdi un média aucune
chance par rapport aux autres qui sont
en chirurgie ou en gériatrie
qu'est ce que tu vas faire elle avait
raison je suis dit on va essayer donc je
me pointe au chantier d'un valaisan
je fais mes soins comme je pense comme
j'ai appris à l'école selon les théories
j'essaye de compenser par la
communication avec nos patients jeu je
fais vraiment de mon mieux
arrive la remise des résultats
j'ai remporté les championnats valaisan
bon voilà assez étonnant je m'y
attendais vraiment pas du tout on va
proposer ensuite de partir au
championnat suisse
je me suis dit ça peut être un défi
encore plus attractif encore plus grand
allons-y et on m'a dit cette fois-ci bon
les romans on n'a pas le même esprit de
compétition qu'en suisse allemand donc
généralement aux championnats suisses
c'est vrai que les romands arrive un peu
moins bien se faire une place parce que
on a moins cette culture de la
compétition
donc je me suis dit pourquoi pas faire
notre place cette fois-ci montré que oui
les romans n'est pas plus bêtes que les
autres et qu'on est aussi capable de
devancer les suisses allemands même si
on
une culture de la compétition qui est
moins imposante
je me suis un petit peu plus s'entraîner
pour les championnats suisses je suis
arrivé j'ai refait la même chose je me
suis concentré avec mon patient j'ai
tout donné sur ma communication et j'ai
vraiment fait tout ce que je pouvais et
j'ai remporté les championnats
sustentant soins au mois de septembre
à ce moment là on m'a proposé de partir
au championnat du monde
et là j'ai même pas eu besoin d'hésiter
où vous me demandez la grandeur du défi
j'ai foncé
je me suis posé aucune question j'y suis
juste allée et pendant les sept derniers
mois qui viennent de passer
je me suis entraîné tout le temps j'ai
sacrifié des moments entre amis des
moments famille des moments avec mon
copain je suis juste allé je les ai
préparé j'ai tout donné et je suis
rentré en russie il ya une semaine où
j'ai fait ces quatre jours de
compétition
cette fois ci j'ai pas été première j'ai
même pas été médaillés mais je les fais
tu suis allé j'ai tenu non seulement les
sept mois de compétition les 7 mois de
préparation pardon mais également les
quatre mois les quatre jours de
compétition elle c'était ça qui était
vraiment le plus chouette j'ai connu
plein de gens j'ai rencontré des
cultures des gens d'autres cultures on a
échangé on a appris des mots dans
d'autres langues
on a appris on a rencontré on a essayé
et c'est ça qui était vraiment le plus
chouette de cette aventure et monde est
le message que j'aimerais vous faire
passer aujourd'hui c'est ne choisissez
pas juste un métier pour faire quelque
chose de votre vie choisissez un travail
que vous allez aimer que vous allez
adorer pour lequel vous voudrez donner
vos tripes
choisissez un métier que vous aurez du
plaisir à exercer tous les jours que
vous allez aimer vous lever tous les
matins que chaque fois que vous y allez
alliés que vous irez vous aurez du
plaisir à y aller
maman elle est dans la salle aujourd'hui
et elle peut vous en témoigner j'ai
jamais vraiment aimé l'école j'étais pas
mauvaise mais ça ne m'intéressait pas
plus que ça ce que j'aimais bien l'école
s'est dit discuter avec mes camarades
quand j'ai commencé mon apprentissage
est en soins j'ai jamais autant aimé
aller à l'école j'ai adoré les cours
parce que j'apprenais ce que j'avais
envie d'apprendre
parce que je découvrais enfin métier que
j'avais choisie est vraiment j'ai adoré
ça ça a été le pur bonheur pendant trois
ans et ceux parmi vous qui auront la
chance de partir en apprentissage
profitez de ces années-là vos années de
formation ce sera les plus belles années
de votre carrière vous allez découvrir
vous allez apprendre vous allez innover
vous allez vraiment arrivé vous saurez
rien et en repartant vous serez pas tout
mais une grande partie poser des
questions vous serez entourés par des
professionnels vous serez entraînés par
des formateurs par des maîtres
d'apprentissage ils sont là pour vous
entoure vous encadrez allez-y vous
contentez pas de réussir votre
apprentissage briller éclatez vous
profitez de ces années là
ce ça va être juste être des années
exceptionnelles vous allez exercer un
métier qui va vous plaire vous allez
apprendre vous allez connaître vous
allez découvrir vous allez peut-être
vous spécialiser dans une branche dans
une autre il n'y a rien de plus beau que
d'adorer le métier qu'on fait que
d'avoir du plaisir à la prendre tous les
jours et juste profiter adoré aimer ce
que vous faites vraiment soyez sûr de
votre choix
si c'est pas le bond pourrait faire
autre chose vous n'êtes pas obligés à 15
ans de choisir le métier pour toute
votre vie si ça va pas vous arrêter vous
chercher autre chose vous faites autre
chose mais quand vous choisissez votre
métier alésia fonds donnés tous
n'importe lequel d'entre vous est
capable d'obtenir un csc n'importe
lequel d'entre vous est capable d'être
champion valaisan n'importe lequel
d'entre vous est capable d'être champion
suisse je suis persuadé que parmi vous
il y en a qui peuvent être champions du
monde
il suffit de le vouloir il suffit de
travailler pour il suffit tout donné et
même si vous n'êtes pas champion du
monde
aller le plus loin que vous pouvez pas
ce que voudrait aucun regret à avoir
tout essayé et tout donner je souhaite
vraiment tout le meilleur pour votre
avenir professionnel qui soit à l'école
au collège à le cg à l'école de commerce
sont en apprentissage
moi j'ai adoré mon apprentissage et tout
ce que je vous souhaite c'est d'adorer
le vôtre merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]